THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR HEARINGS HERE
IN THE -- STREET BUILDING I
ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM THE BEGINNER
HEARING FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE NINE
SEVEN THREE EIGHT NINE TWO
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THE
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
AND MUTED AND YOU WILL NOT BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS CHAIR
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
ARE HAVE TO CONNECTIONS MUTED
TODAY WE HAVE FOURTEEN ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THERE ARE SEVEN
ITEMS ON CONSENT AS FOLLOWS
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT SIXTY
ONE BY SIR LIMóN ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE FOUR
CENTER LAYERED ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB NINE OH SEVEN BY CENTER PAN
I ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB TEN FIFTY
FOUR PERCENT OR A CHILL ABOUT
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB TEN NINETY
BY CENTER HER TADO AND ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN S. B. TEN NINETY
THREE BY CENTRE TODD AT ALSO
NOTE THAT ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
STR EIGHT WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY WILL BE RESET FOR A FUTURE
HEARING THAT MEANS WE'LL HEAR
A TOTAL OF SIX ITEMS TODAY
BEFORE WE BEGIN PRESENTATION OF
BILLS -- CONSULTANT LET'S PLEASE
-- LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
ITS OWN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN'T HEAR HERE
COURTESY OF
HERE HURTADO
HURTADO KAMLAGER
HERE I SOON
JONES JONES OKAY
ALL RIGHT AKORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU SO
-- CORRECT CELEBRATE
WHERE GUSTS FIRST START WITH
THAT OUR FIRST ITEM BEFORE US IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR BY CENTER SKINNER WELCOME
A PLEASE COME UP TO THE PODIUM
PLEASE PRESENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SO
I'M PRESENTING SP EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR THE HOPE FOR CHILDREN
-- I THINK MANY OF US REALIZE
JUST HOW DEVASTATING COVERED WAS
IN TERMS OF DEATH RATES AND
WHAT WE PERHAPS DIDN'T PAY AS
MUCH ATTENTION TO IS HOW MANY
CHILDREN LOS A PARENT
OR PRIMARY CARE GIVER TO COPE
-- NATIONALLY THE ESTIMATE IS
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN LOST A PARENT
IN WITHIN OUR STATE YES MADE
AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WAS THAT MORE THAN TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA LOST APPEARED FOR
PRIMARY CARE GIVER SOUTH OF
IT THE OTHER UNFORTUNATE THING
IS WELL ANY OF US NEVER ONE OF
US COULD HAVE GOTTEN COBIT YOU
ARE MORE LIKELY TO GET CODED
IF YOU WERE LOW INCOME FOR
A LOW WAGE WORKER AND THERE
ARE MANY FACTORS THAT CAUSED
THAT NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH
IS THAT WHILE SOME OF US WERE
ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME OR BE
ABLE TO STAY AT HOME FATHERS
HAD TO GO TO WORK AND HAD LESS
PROTECTION FROM THE VIRUS SO
THE WE DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBERS BUT A LARGE SENSE
OF THOSE TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN WHO LOST A PARENT
OR PRIMARY CARE TAKER OR BOTH
PARENTS WERE FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS CREATE A HOPE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE CHILDREN
COOL ALREADY WERE IN LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND WHO NOW FACE
FURTHER ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
IN ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN WHO WERE IN LONG TERM
FOSTER CARE AND THE REASON THAT
WE'VE ADDED THE KIDS IN LONG
TERM FOSTER CARE IS BECAUSE
ESSENTIALLY THEY ALSO DO NOT
HAVE PARENTS TO RELY ON BEYOND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THESE HOPE ACCOUNTS IS CREATE
THAT SAID THAT THERE SOMEONE'S
GOING TO HAVE YOUR BACK ONCE
YOU BECOME EIGHTEEN YOUR NOT
JUST ABANDON NOW YOU CAN
SAY WELL WHY JUST WHEN YOU
TURN EIGHTEEN WELL FOR MANY OF
THE CHILDREN WHO LOST A PARENT
TO COVE IT IF THEIR PARENT
PARTY WAS IN A WORK SITUATION
THAT CONTRIBUTED TO SOCIAL
SECURITY THEN THE CHILDREN GET
A DEATH BENEFIT IN AFFECTED
SURVIVOR BENEFIT BOND AND
SO THEY DO HAVE SOME INCOME
TELL THEIR EIGHTEEN IT'S
AFTER EIGHTEEN THAT THERE THEN
POTENTIALLY LEFT NOW THE OTHER
THING THAT THE BILL DOES IS
RECOGNIZES THAT SOME NUMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN WHO LOST
THEIR PARENTS TO COATED DID NOT
HAVE PARENTS WHO QUALIFIED FOR
THE FEDERAL SURVIVOR BENEFITS
EITHER BECAUSE THEY WERE THE
PARENT WAS TOO YOUNG IT DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH QUARTERS OF WORK TO
QUALIFY WHERE THEY WORKED IN A
JOB THAT DIDN'T QUALIFY FOR THE
FEDERAL BENEFITS OR THEY WOULD
PERHAPS WORD IN THE WORK FORCE
BECAUSE OF PARENTING OR OTHER
RESPONSIBILITY SO THIS BILL ALSO
CREATES THE CAL SURVIVOR PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE REPLACEMENT FOR
FEDERAL SURVIVOR BENEFITS FOR
THOSE KIDS WHO LOST THEIR PARENT
OR PRIMARY CARE GIVER AND DON'T
QUALIFY FOR THE FEDERAL SURVIVOR
BENEFITS TOWARD LIKE TO HAVE
MY WITNESSES MIGHT IN SUPPORT
CAN MAKE A GASCONS FROM GRACE
AND THEN POVERTY NOW OF --
SPONSOR IN -- TONYA OF A
CLEARLY -- WHO WILL EXPLAIN
HER CIRCUMSTANCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH A CENTER SKINNER OF BEFORE
YOU BRING ON THOSE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT I JUST WANTED THAT SAY
THAT AGAIN FIRST OF ALL IT SO I
INDICATE THAT WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO ANYONE WITH THE TESTIFIED
SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
ON THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
AND TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS V. COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE -- IT'S GOING TO
BE -- TWO MINUTES PER WITNESS
TOTAL FOUR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE TO THE SIDE OF YOUR FROM
AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
SAID AS A ANNOUNCED ALL OTHERS
WILL SWITCHING TO TESTIFY IN
THIS LIMITED COMMENTS YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR THE FIRST --
THE PRESENTATION PRESENTATIONS
TESTIMONY FROM YOUR TO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT -- MODERATOR PLEASE
BE SURE OF BUT LET'S BRING ON
THE LINE SHOULD MICAH GASKINS --
FROM GRACE AND -- TANYA
GERRY AND -- -- WILL BE AND
I GUESS IS IT WILL BEGIN WITH US
TO MAKE A GASKINS ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE SHOEMAKER
GASKINS -- YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
I'LL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTE WARNING
IF YOU GO OVER THAT UNFORTUNATE
MEANS THE SECOND WITNESS WILL
HAVE LESS TIME SO GIVE YOU TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN
WELCOME THANK YOU
CAN PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT TESTIFIED TODAY I THANK
YOU GAP INTEGRATION AND HELP
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AND
WE ARE PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR SB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR WITH LIBERATION
THE GENERATION AND THE PROPERTY
CALIFORNIA TODAY IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A MORAL AND PRACTICAL
IMPAIRED IT'S REDUCED FIVE THREE
RIGHT WELL DEATH I REPEAT THE
BUDGET SURPLUS WE CAN DECIDE
THE PLAN AND YOU SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OFF TO WORK FOR
MORE PROFIT FEATURE SB THAT HAD
THE CHANCE TO REVERSE THE FACT
THAT TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
BLACK HOLE FOR NINETY PERCENT OF
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS HAS YOUR
NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
BASICALLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THOSE OFTEN BY COLD IN NINETEEN
AND OTHERS LEFT NAVIGATING THE
EDGES OF OUR ECONOMY LET'S BE
CLEAR WELL COULD NOT BE LOADED
JUST WORKING HARD AND SAVING
MORE MONEY BUT BUILT OVER
GENERATIONS AND OUR GOVERNMENT
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING
LUCKILY THOSE DIVING CALL THE
NINETEEN HAD LET THE THOUSANDS
OF OUR BABIES IF YOU HEARD AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY SEVEN WELL NO
NOT THOUSAND WILL NO LONGER HAVE
THE CANCER CARE GIVER THAT THEY
WERE EXPECTING TO HELP THEM AND
OVER ONE THIRD OF COFFEE EVERY
YEAR AGE OUT AND EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS IF WE CARE ABOUT
GIVING THESE CHILDREN A BRIGHTER
FUTURE WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFERS
ARE CRITICAL TO SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD
BECAUSE THE CHILDREN WILL NOT
HAVE THAT SAME THE COURT THE
PROPOSAL BUT COUNTY PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND THE FREEDOM FOR
THEM TO PICK YOU THEIR DREAM
SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR ALSO SEEKS
TO HELP THE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE SURVIVOR
BENEFIT COULD YOU HURT UNIT BOTH
FAMILIES WHO HAVE PAID THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE PARENTS DID
NOT HAVE ENOUGH WORK CREDITS
TO QUALIFY THEIR CHILDREN AND
THE CHILDREN ESSENTIALLY WILL
GO OUT WITHOUT SUPPORT THE
FATE THAT INTERVENE TO HELP
INSURE THEIR CURRENT ECONOMIC
STABILITY OF ALL OF THE CHILDREN
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
IPHONE X. THE EIGHT FIVE FOUR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE SECOND WITNESS
-- WATER PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE -- TANYA GERRY
THIS IS YOUR GARY AVAILABLE
THE MODERATORS AND YOU
MODERATOR SHE'S A SPANISH
SPEAKER SO ROOM FOR HELP
CALIFORNIA OKAY IS IS SOMEONE
GOING TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING I'M INTERPRETING
FOR HER YES HER TESTIMONY
COMING ONLINE SOON OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ON
EXCELLENT THANK YOU
GOOD ON YOU LINES OF ALL OKAY
-- LET ME KNOW IF I HAVE YOU
FORMER HELLO
SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE GATED EMAIL
BOB YEAH THE GOVERNMENT
WILL BE FOR MEDIA
ONLY ONLY RENTAL DIPLOMA
FELLOW SAID MAYBE IT GAVE
YEP A HUNDRED WILL
BENEFIT THE COMPANY MODEL
WELCOME TO OUR SHOW THE
COSBY HELLO HELLO HELLO
HELLO THE COMPUTER FROM YOU
WWW COMMITTEE TELL
BOTH POLITICAL SCHOOLS
INFORMATICA COMMITTEE
WORKING A COUPLE NOTHING
MULLIN THE POLITICAL
SOLUTION BILLABLE
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE HOPING
FOR SOMETHING THAT CAN GET
HELLO
NO NEED OF INTERNET FEELS
WONDERFUL JANET DEVELOPING
PEOPLE TO FIND OUT WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR FOR THAT OTHER
IF YOU'LL GIVE ME A FOLLOW
UP ON RONALD TOTAL
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
WILL BE FILLED WITH LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR THE TECHNICAL
BUT GIVEN APPROVAL
THE MOBILE MOBILE ACCORDING
WHEN FOR PUTTING PEOPLE
THE LOCAL ONLY ADDED ON
THE COMMUTER MOVIE RECORDED
A LOT OF BUSINESSES
FOR FOR ME BUT I THOUGHT
IF I COULD FEEL UPSET WHEN
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO PEOPLE
CAN ALSO LOG IN WITH
YOUR FROM THE JAMAICA
FROM PEOPLE WITHOUT A
SHOT ON THE
OPALA FIFTY PEOPLE
THE TROUBLE WITH THE WHOLE
OF THE NATIONAL PEOPLE'S
SIX THE LITTLE
MERMAID UPSWING TOTAL
YOUR AVAILABLE TO MEDICAL
CARE THIS WILL BE A
OPENING LOOK AT
HI MY NAME IS TANYA KITA I AM
A MOTHER OF THREE CHILDREN SIX
YEAR CARDINALS FIVE YEAR OLD
DILLON AND ONE YEAR OLD K¿T I'M
HERE TO TELL MY STORY OF HOW
COLD IT HAS IMPACTED MY FAMILY
AND DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY I
WAS PREGNANT WITH MY THIRD BABY
HAITI MY HUSBAND CONTINUE TO
WORK AT A COMPANY THAT MAKES
HAND SANITIZER HIM FORTUNATELY
CONTRACTED COBIT WHILE HE WAS
AT WORK AND WITHIN A WEEK I
CONTRACTED KOPET MY HUSBAND
WAS WITH UNDOCUMENTED AND DID
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL WE
WERE SO WORRIED ABOUT THE COST
OF MEDICAL CARE AND THE DANGER
OF STATE IN A HOSPITAL WHILE
PREGNANT THAT WE TRY TO SELF
CORTINA HOME FOR A WEEK OUR
HEALTH WAS GETTING WORSE AND MY
DOCTOR IMMEDIATELY ADVISED ME
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE
MY PREGNANCY WAS IN DANGER I
HAVE TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY C.
SECTION AND WAS IN THE I SEE
YOU WHEN I HEARD THE NEWS ON
MY HUSBAND WITH INTEGRATED THE
TO HIS CONDITION IS ONLY FOUR
DAYS AFTER ARRIVING AT THE
HOSPITAL THAT HE WAS INTUBATED
THE DOCTORS DID EVERYTHING
THEY COULD TO KEEP MY HUSBAND
ALIVE I BEGGED THEM TO KEEP
THE FATHER OF MY CHILDREN ALIVE
MY HUSBAND DIED ON DECEMBER
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY
HE NEVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HOLD OUR DAUGHTER HAITI IN
HIS ARMS HE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SEE HIS CHILDREN GROW UP AND
BECOME ADULTS I LIVE WITH
THE TRAUMA OF GOING THROUGH THAT
NINE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS BOOK
ABOUT HOW THIS WILL AFFECT THE
MENTAL WELL BEING OF MY CHILDREN
THIS WAS NOT THE ONLY LOSS IN
OUR FAMILY MY MOTHER IN LAW ALSO
PASSED AWAY THREE MONTHS AFTER
MY HUSBAND PASSED MY STEPFATHER
ALSO PASSED IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I KNOW WE ARE NOT
THE ONLY ONES CARRYING THIS
PAIN AND MANY FAMILIES FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY LATINO FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED MY HUSBAND TRY
TO AVOID IN PERSON WORK TO KEEP
OUR FAMILY SAFE UNFORTUNATELY
REMOTE WORK WAS NOT AN OPTION
FOR MY HUSBAND WHO IS CONSIDERED
AN ESSENTIAL WORKER NOW I HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE OF MY
CHILDREN ALONE IT'S HARD BEING
A SINGLE MOM FOR THIS REASON
THE SUPPORT OF THE HOPE ACCOUNTS
WOULD BE SOMETHING IMPORTANT
FOR THE FUTURES OF MY CHILDREN
AND I DON'T WANT ANY LIMITATIONS
FOR MY CHILDREN WHETHER IT'S
HAVING THE RESOURCES TO BUY
A HOME OR TREES IN THE SCHOOL
OF THEIR DREAMS I WANT THEM
TO DREAM ABOUT AN ACHIEVABLE
FUTURE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK AND ACTUALLY BEFORE YOU
GO FIRST OF ALL CAN YOU JUST
ASSURE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
AS AN INTERPRETER YES AND A
HUMANIST -- POLICY ANALYST FOR
GRAYSON THANK YOU AND BEFORE
YOU GO ALSO -- BECAUSE I CAN'T
AFFORD I CAN'T SPEAK SPANISH
CAN YOU THANK THE SCARY FOR
HER RESIGNATION IT FINANCE
AND I'LL GET IT OFF THE LIST
PRICES FOR -- PROVE PROGRAMS
THROUGH TESTIMONY AND ALSO
EXPRESS OUR SYMPATHIES TO
HER FOR FOR HER LOSS EDIAMOND
THURMOND ALSO SALUTE FOR
LUCKILY THIS WAS POSSIBLE LAST
THANK YOU OKAY --
THANK YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY
SO WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR -- WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM
TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SINGLE
INCOME AT THE MICROPHONE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED -- MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON TO THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO WISHED -- YEAH
ARE YOU -- FLEETS HE'S COME ON
SORRY I APOLOGIZE HELLO CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS CODY VAN
FELTON -- I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH WHEN I TURNED EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD I WAS LEFT ABANDONED
-- NO SUPPORT A
HOMELESS -- KNOWLEDGE AS ITS
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITIONAL
SORRY SORRY -- PUTTING THEM HELD
AND I WORK WITH J. BAY I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT YOUR
STORY THOUGH -- BY -- ONLINE
-- BUT A COMMITTEE SIGNATURE
STORY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OKAY SEE NO INCOME AT THE
MICROPHONE -- LET'S MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
-- NAME OR POSITION POSITION
IF YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
SUPPORT SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO FIVE FIRST YOU GO TO
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
PLEASE BEGIN
THANK YOU
I'LL GO AHEAD LINE FORTY
MICHAEL COMMITTEE ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE TO
THE STAR CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
TO GREENSPAN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE APPRECIATION
FOR CALIFORNIA CONTACTED
SUPPORT SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS DANIEL ONE ZERO
WITH CHILDREN NOW CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THE NEXT TO THE TO LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS
PATHOLOGY DR WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
REPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS MEXICO'S
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
CAMPING THEN OFF THEN ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THANKS WHAT LINE
HIT THE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
A GOOD AFTERNOON ELECTED GOT
YOUR GOVERNMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JORDAN THANK THANK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CONNECTION
OR STEVE LACY WHAT VEHICLE
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIFTY FOUR
OH FOR CHILDREN ACT TWENTY
TWENTIETH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TO LINE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOU CARE
MEMBERS MONEY SOME OF THEM
DR STATE POLICY PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SP BEFORE WITH
LIKE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE BILLS THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO AARON HOLD THEM WITH A
LEGAL FOR EVERY CHILD IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXPERTNESS
NINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI GOOD AFTERNOON WORKING ON
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR FROM THE BIRTH EQUITY
ADVOCATE THE PROJECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS BARBARA GARAND --
EIGHT POLICY ADVOCATE FOR THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN
AND WE'RE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT LINE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
I FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR THE
FIRE ALARM TO GO TO NINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI A LOT MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT OF A THREE
EIGHT FIVE FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT TO THE CLIENT SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS THIS IS MOLLY SHEEHAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF HOPE FOR CHILDREN ACT THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THE NEXT LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THESE INDUSTRIAL MY NAME IS
OKAY GREAT MY NAME'S DAVID
ABRAMSON AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT BIGGEST
OBJECTION TO THIS BILL IS THAT
-- -- -- RECEIVE I UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE BUT I THINK THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE FOR COMMUNITIES
THERE ON THE FRONT LINE AND
CIRCLE JUST DISABLED I AM
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE
-- DAVE ABRAMS IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF I'M SORRY IF
I WAS PUBLIC COMMENT THAT RIGHT
OKAY ENDED SUPPORT CORRECT
YES IN SUPPORT ACT THANK
YOU SIR OUR NEXT WITNESS
NEXT GO TO LINE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY FIFTY FIVE TWO LINES OPEN
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAMES
STEPHANIE GRAHAM THE CHIEF OF
STAFF AND POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
ARE CALLING INTO STRONG SUPPORT
SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
WE JUST A MOMENT FOR THE NEXT
WITNESS -- LOCAL CLIENT
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THESE BEGIN IPHONE BEFORE
HI MY NAME IS MERRY THE
MENACE I'M LOOKING FOR
A NEW STUFF GOING INTO
FLORIDA SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
I THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO MY NAME IS ALISON CALLING
FROM HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND
CALLING STRONG SUPPORTER OF
AT EIGHT FIVE EIGHT FOUR WOULD
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THIS TIME THERE'S NO OTHER
LINK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY SCHEDULED LEAD WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO FOR
NOW MOVES TO ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED -- SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION --
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY PLEASE
HE LED BY AN OPPOSITION
THAT SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR AM
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
OKAY
EVERY TIME THERE'S NO WINNING
QUEUE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIRTY TWO S½ APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN
THE BILL OKAY BILLS AND IF
I SENATE CORTESE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CASEY
NINE -- SO SENATE'S GONNA THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING FORTH
THIS BILL ACTUALLY DID HAVE A
COUPLE OF BRIEF QUESTIONS SO
FIRST QUESTION IS IS THAT --
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE QUALIFY THE
DEAL DO YOU KNOW IF -- IF THE
PARENTS FOR EXAMPLE WERE GIG
WORKERS BUT THEY HAVE THEM
BUT THEY HAVE HAD -- EST ARE
NOT BECAUSE WITH THOSE THEIR
CHILDREN THEREFORE ALSO BE
ANOTHER GROUP TO PERHAPS WOULD
MISS OUT ON THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
-- IT DEPENDS SOME GIG WORKERS
WOULD NOT WOULD HAVE MISSED OUT
SOME NOT IT DEPENDS AND IF THEY
HAD WERE SET UP TO BE PAYING
INTO THE -- THAT FRONT OKAY
SO THE WORDS THEN AGAIN THAT
THEIR CHILDREN WOULD NOT AND
OF COURSE IT MAY BE A HIGH
RISK SITUATION AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION I HAVE -- OTHER
YOU MAY END UP TO ANSWERING
IT FINANCES THAT SO THE FUNDS
THAT WERE WOULD YOU PUT IN
THESE ACCOUNTS -- WOULD THEY BE
INVESTED BY THE STATE WHO WHO
WOULD MANAGE THE FUNDS UNTIL
THE UNTIL THE CHILD BECOMES
EIGHTEEN RIGHT SO AND WE'RE
WE ALL THOSE ARE TO BE PART
OF THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT --
LET'S JUST SAY IF IT'S WITH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE FOR EXAMPLE
WE WOULD HOPE THAT THEY WOULD BE
-- PUT IN SOME KIND OF ACCOUNT
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO GAIN VALUE
-- SO THAT THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN AT THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE
POSITIVE DEPENDING ON THE AGE
SO IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE OLDER
THERE'D NEED TO BE A LITTLE
MORE MONEY PUT IN RIGHT NOW
AGAIN ASSUMING THIS RIGHT NOW
-- BECAUSE IT WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO GAIN AS MUCH IN VALUE AND IF
YOU'RE YOUNGER THAN WOULD HAVE
A LONGER TIME NOW OBVIOUSLY
EVEN THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS WILL
END UP BEING NEGOTIATED BECAUSE
-- YOU KNOW IF THAT IS A
BUDGETARY ISSUE AND IF YOU
KNOW WHETHER IT'S AN APPROACH
OR WHETHER IT'S LATER -- BUT
WE'VE PUT IN WE'VE BOTH PUT
IN A SUGGESTED AMOUNT THAT ONE
WOULD WANT TO HAVE DEPOSITED
AND WE'VE ALSO PUT IN WHAT WE
THOUGHT THE INCOME THRESHOLD
SO THIS WHAT ARE YOU DIDN'T
-- I MAY NOT HAVE SPECIFIED IS
THAT IF I IF IT'S A HIGH INCOME
-- IF IT'S A CHILD FROM HIGH
INCOME FAMILIES LOST A PAIR
IN -- OUR PRIMARY CARE GIVER
THEY MAY NOT TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE HEALTH ACCOUNTS OKAY
ALL RIGHT WELL LOOK FOR TO --
THE FINAL RESULTS WHEN IT HITS
THE FLOOR BUT I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AGAIN
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE POINTED OUT
IN YOUR INTRODUCTION THAT WE --
TRY TO ORGANIZE A CLOSE BECAUSE
YOUR CLOTHES IS THE WEALTH
GAP BUT AT LEAST THE LEAST --
GIVE SOME RESOURCES -- TO --
THESE YOUTH SO THAT THEY CAN
HOPEFULLY GET -- THAT THEY'RE
NOT TO DISADVANTAGED BECAUSE
FOR THAT WAY AT THE START AND
THEY'RE VERY DISADVANTAGED
ODDS TO OFTEN SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE YES THANK
YOU I THINK WE'VE HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH OUR WITNESSES AND ALSO OF
COURSE THE EMOTIONAL TESTIMONY
OF -- DISAGREE AGREEABLY
-- AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU -- SO THE
EMOTION IS TO PASS BUT BRIEF
BUT REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT GOVERNS OF FINANCE IT'S
BEEN SECONDED BY SENATOR CORTESE
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN I ASK JONES
JONES COURTESY
CORTEZ THE I HURTADO
HURTADO KAMLAGER
HI KAMLAGER HI OKAY THE BILL
HAS THREE VOTES TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX -- BY SEN
RUBIO SO THAT'S S. B. NINE
FOURTEEN BY CENTER RUBIO WELCOME
AND IF
WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M PROUD TODAY TO
PRESENT SB NINE ONE FOUR THAT
HELPED ACT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE HOMELESS EQUITY FOR LEFT
BEHINDS POPULATIONS AS OUR
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONTINUE EFFORTS TO SOLVE
THE HOMELESS CRISIS WE MUST
ENSURE THAT WE ARE INCLUSIVE
OF UNIQUE NEEDS AND EXPERIENCES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS MAY
BE FACING NATIONALLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE LEADING
DRIVERS HAVE HOMELESSNESS
FOR WOMEN APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF AND HOUSE
WOMEN REPORT TO MESS TAKE
VIOLENCE AS AN IMMEDIATE COSTS
OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS AND
THE TWENTY TWENTY HOMELESS
POINT IN TIME COUNT IN LOS
ANGELES FORTY NINE PERCENT OF
UNSHELTERED WOMEN AND SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT OF UNSHELTERED
TRANS GENDER INDIVIDUALS
REPORTED EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE BUT DESPITE THE
STATISTICS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SERVICES HAVE BEEN GROSSLY
UNDERFUNDED GIVEN THE VALUE
OF AND MATT NEEDS OF THE
ELEVEN LARGEST CONTINUANCE
OF CARE ONLY ONE ALLOCATE
THE PERCENTAGE OF FUNDING
EQUIVALENT TO THE PERCENTAGE
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE HELP BACK WILL
ENSURE THAT THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE INCLUDED IN THE
WORK THAT CITIES COUNTIES AND
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS CURRENTLY
DUE TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AT
THE STATE LEVEL THE HELP ACT
WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS TO SET MEASURABLE
GOALS TOWARDS PREVENTING AND
ENDING HOMELESSNESS FOR THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THE BILL
IS COSPONSORED BY THREE LEADING
ORGANIZATIONS AT THE CENTER
OF THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
THE HOMELESSNESS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE HOBBIT THREE
ORGANIZATIONS DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER RAINBOW'S SERVICES AND
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
AND MUST TAKE VIOLENCE ARE
CO SPONSORS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS SUPPORTED BY
NEARLY SIXTY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HOMELESS SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS IF I MADE JOINING
ME HERE TODAY ON THE PHONE ARE
TWO WITNESSES TO SHERMAN MORE
ABOUT THE HELP ACT AND ITS
IMPORTANCE I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
ELIZABETH EASTLAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF RAMBLE SERVICES AND
CALLING GONZALEZ AS SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH SAYS A
RUBIO MODERATE PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE TO TO LEAD WITNESSES
ON SB NINE FOURTEEN ELIZABETH
EASTLAND -- IS A VECTOR RAMOS
SERVICES AND COLLEEN GONZALEZ
-- AND -- SO ELIZABETH
EASTLAND -- PLEASE BEGIN
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
APIECE TOTAL FORMATS TOGETHER
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE ME YES
BECAUSE HE CAN'T SLEEP AGAIN
HELLO WONDERFUL YOU DEFINITELY
HAVE BEEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HEARING
MY FACT MARK MOONEY IN SUPPORT
SB NINE FOURTEEN MY NAME IS A
LITTLE BIT EASTLAND AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BRING THOSE
SERVICES AT THE TIME SERVICE
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING SHELTER
AND SUPPORT SERVICES ANYONE
IMPACTED BY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN LOS ANGELES AT IN ORDER
RUBIO STATED THEY LEFT THE
VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE LEADING
DRIVERS OF HOMELESSNESS FOR
WOMEN NATIONALLY ONE THIRD
OF ALL HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
OUR AND THE COMPANY WHEN EIGHTY
NINE FOURTEEN SUPPORT THE
POPULATION'S LIKE BASKING IN
GENDER EQUITY LENS AND LOCAL
AND STATE HOW MUCH RESPONSE
AND THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THAT THESE POPULATIONS
ARE INCLUDED IN THE ACT OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE BELIEVED
COUNTIES AND HOMELESS CONTINUUM
OF CARE ARE ALREADY PASSED
AWAY AND -- TAKING SUCH AS
DEVELOPING THE LOCAL LANDSCAPE
ANALYSIS AND IDENTIFYING GOALS
FOR REDUCING HOMELESSNESS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THESE
ARE NOT NEW ACTIVITY NOR ARE
WE ESTABLISHING NEW POPULATIONS
OF HOMELESS PEOPLE RATHER SB
NINE FOURTEEN SIMPLY ENSURE
THAT GENDER EQUITY LAND THAT
THESE POPULATIONS AND THE VICTIM
SERVICE PROVIDERS SHELTERING
SURVIVORS -- INCLUDING IMPORTANT
PRIVACY AND CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE SURVIVORS
SAFETY PROHIBITS FROM ENTERING
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
INTO THE HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM -- HMIS
USED BY OUR PARTNERS AND THE
HOUSING THE HOMELESS FIELD
URGENTLY HMIS DATA IS OFTEN
THE ONLY DATA SOURCE USED IN
THE ASSESSMENT SINGLE STANDING
IGNORING THE SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF DOUBT THAT THAT VICTIM
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE AVAILABLE
ABOUT THE HOME MISTER RIGHT
THE THIRD HE ADDED THAT VICTIM
SERVICES ISN'T CONSIDERED THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS DON'T
GET THE DISSERVICE FOCUSED WHEN
IT COMES TO SETTING PRIORITIES
AND GOALS WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING
OUR SYSTEMS OF CARE TO RECOGNIZE
THE VULNERABLE POPULATION AND
TAKE MEASURABLE ACTIONS TO
SUPPORT THEM I DON'T THINK
SENATOR RUBIO FOR HER AMAZING
LEADERSHIP FIRST YOU ALL TO
SUPPORT THAT AT ALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO COLLEEN GONZALEZ
HELLO HELLO WELCOME HERE HERE
YES YES WE CAN PLEASE BEGIN
AB HERE CHAIR PANEL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR HEARING MY TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FOURTEEN
HI MY NAME IS COLLEEN
GONZALEZ AND I AM A SURVIVOR
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- I
WOULD WITH MY PARTNER FOR TEN
YEARS AND DURING THE BUTTE
AND MANIPULATION AND PHYSICAL
VIOLENCE I TRIED TO CALL THE
POLICE MOST OF THE TIME BUT NO
ONE EVER THOUGHT IN TODAY
I KNEW THAT I HAD TO LEAVE
WORK AFTER MY DAUGHTER I DON'T
THINK IT NEEDS TO I KNEW HE
WAS LEARNING VIOLATE HAVING
AN ACT NOT FROM EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA I CALLED RAINBOW HOTLINE
IN THE NEXT THING I KNEW
I WAS SITTING IN A SHELTER
PARKING LOT WITH MY KIDS AND
IF MANY PERSONAL BELONGINGS
AS I COULD TAKE WITH ME
I ALMOST DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE
TO STAY RAINBOW WAS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AT THE TIME THEY
WERE ABLE TO TAKE ANYONE ELSE
PLAN -- BUT ONE GREAT THING
-- NAME MARIA HE COULDN'T
LEAVE ME AND MY BABIES ON THE
STREET IT'S NOT A RAINBOW AND
MARIA I WOULD HAVE EITHER LEFT
IN MY CAR WITH MY TWO BABIES
ARE GONE BACK MY PARTNER
UNFORTUNATELY MULTIVIBRATOR HAVE
TO THE HOMELESSNESS AND VIOLENCE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS LIKE TO
PAY FOR THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE
DAYS BUT THEN WHAT I THANK
GARY NOT KNOWING WHAT COULD
HAPPEN YOU'RE EITHER IN DURING
VIOLENCE AT HOME AND NOT KNOWING
IF THEY'RE GOING TO WAKE UP
THE NEXT DAY OR BEING HOMELESS
I'M ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T GET THE
SERVICE WE ARE ENOUGH TO GO
AROUND I ARGUED TO THE COURT
SB NINE FOURTEEN LET NO SURVIVOR
HALF USED BETWEEN SLEEPING
ON THE STREETS ARE GOING BACK
WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE WITH
RECOGNIZING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS AND UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY RIGHT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FOURTEEN WILL BEGIN HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
C. KNOWN APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE -- WILL NOW MOVE
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FOURTEEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION THANK YOU
DO YOU LIKE THE CURRENT SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FOURTEEN IN A PRESS
ONE ZERO UP AS WE GO TO LINE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS CLARA CARTER I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL
CITY ASSOCIATION OF LOS ANGELES
REGISTER I FOUND A BULLET MULLIN
PLAYED THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE A
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK A KRAMER
MATER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TO ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
COLOGNE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
AND GRAPHIC VIOLENCE
PROBLEM POST FONG THE COURT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT TO THE TWO NINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS
LOOK IT UP ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THE NEXT TO A TO LINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ROBERT BATEMAN WITH THE HIGH
CENTER FOR FAMILY LAW HAULING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU X. WITNESS
THANKS FOR THE TIME
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINES OPEN
I WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON TO MARK TOOK OUT
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO A TO LINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN
RIGHT AT THIS POINT THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE RIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE FOURTEEN -- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY FORMAL ASK UP THE
OPPOSITION THAT SAID IT'S
SCHEDULED TO TESTIFY -- SO WILL
THEN OPEN IT UP FOR -- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT -- SO WE'LL BEGIN
WITH -- ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OTHER WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE FOURTEEN
C. NINE S. YOUR IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FOURTEEN
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
IF YOU LIKE TO COMMENT
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIS IS MOLLY SHEEHAN
AT THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL I MISSED MY MY
NUMBER EARLIER THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
RIGHT THAT WAS A SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FOURTEEN
AND THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATE
LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF SENATE COLLIDER NO BUT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME OF
THE BILL OKAY TO BILLS INTO
VICE -- SORRY COMMA AFTER
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- SO RUBIO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THAT I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
-- YOU KNOW IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS THIS AND
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON HOMELESS THAT'S ISSUES
IN PARTICULAR THAT PERTAINS
TO THIS PORTABLE POPULATION
WITH AN EQUITY LENS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A MEASURABLE
GOALS AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
MY SPONSORS AND WITH THAT I
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR RUBIO SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING IT'S BEEN
SECONDED BY CENTER COME LONGER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CAN HI CAN I JONES
JONES OR DOES HE LIVE
OR DOES HE I HURTADO
HURTADO KAMLAGER I
AM A GUY BILL KALINA THREE
VOTES -- WILL HOLD OF --
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANKS SO MUCH AND
RUBIO ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB TEN SEVENTY ONE BY
CENTER -- BURKE NAY WELCOME
THANK YOU THIS YEAR AND MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF AND IN PARTICULAR
MERCED CA FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SP TEN SEVENTY
ONE WHICH WILL EXPEDITE THE
APPEAL PROCESS OF CARE BENEFITS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS WHEN YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE AND THEIR CAREGIVERS APPEAL
A DENIAL FOSTER CARE BENEFITS
OR RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL THEY
MUST WAIT MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS
FROM ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING IF
THE PIER THEIR APPEAL BASED ON
INFORMATION CONTAINED IN THE
USE CONFIDENTIAL JUVENILE CASE
FILE -- LAW LACKS CLARITY ON
WHAT TYPES OF RECORDS SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE IN THE STATE
HEARINGS INVOLVING FOSTER
YOUTH OUR YOUTH AND CAREGIVERS
WHO ULTIMATELY PREVAILED THE
HEARING THIS MEANS LONG DELAYS
IN RECEIVING CRITICAL FUNDS THAT
PRETTY A YOUNG PERSON NEEDS
ARE HOUSING OTHERS CENTRAL'S
THEREFORE SB TEN SEVENTY ONE
WELLS ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES AND
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS ON --
INVOLVING A MINOR IN FOSTER
CARE TO HAVE ACCESS TO JUVENILE
CASE FILES OR PURPOSE OF THAT
HEARING THIS BILL WILL STILL
IS TIME LINES ALSO BY WHICH
COUNTIES MUST MAKE PERMANENT
RECORDS AVAILABLE I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO GAUGE WAS
STAKEHOLDERS WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS THE SABRINA FORTE
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS OKAY
THANK YOU AND -- SABRINA FOR
TASTE RIGHT HERE SO -- WELCOME
A PLEASE BEGIN GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN MEMBERS SABRINA FOR TAKE
FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
SB TEN SEVENTY ONE THE ALLIANCE
REPRESENTS ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES EACH YEAR AND APPEALING
DENIALS TERMINATIONS AND
REDUCTIONS OF CRITICAL FUNDING
THAT THEY USED TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH IN THEIR
CARE AND ALTHOUGH COUNTIES DO
THEIR BEST TO MAXIMIZE THESE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES FOR YOUTH
IN CARE ERRORS CAN OF COURSE
OCCURRED AND THAT'S WHY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ADMINISTERS A PROCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO APPEAL AN ADVERSE
DECISION BY THE COUNTY LIKE
EVERYTHING CONNECTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
ARE CONFIDENTIAL AND THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE RESOLVED WITHIN
NINETY DAYS THE LAW REQUIRES
COUNTY AGENCIES TO MAKE
AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES PRIOR TO
THE HEARING A POSITION STATEMENT
DEFENDING ITS DECISION BUT
ANYTHING FROM THE IT'S JUVENILE
COURT CASE FILED ITS KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL I SENATOR UMBERG
DESCRIBES ACCESSING THOSE FILES
CAN TAKE MONTHS OR YEARS WELL
BEYOND THE PERIOD OF TIME THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THE HEARING TO BE
RESOLVED AND ALTHOUGH THE YOUTH
AND FAMILIES THAT WE WORK WITH
RECEIVE RETROACTIVE PAYMENTS
AFTER PREVAILING AT HEARING
EXTENDED GAPS IN FINANCIAL
SUPPORT CAN DESTABILIZE A USE
PLACEMENT TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WAS DENIED
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE BENEFITS
AND SUBMITTED AN ADMINISTRATIVE
APPEAL THERE WAS A DISPUTE OVER
WHETHER THE JUVENILE COURT MADE
THE PROPER ORDERS TO QUALIFY
THE YOUNG PERSON FOR EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE FUNDING IT TOOK
EIGHT MONTHS FOR THE YOUTH
AND HER LEGAL AID ATTORNEY
TO OBTAIN THE JUVENILE COURT
ORDERS AT ISSUE AND THE IT WAS
HOMELESS DURING THAT TIME THE
GOAL OF THE SPELL IS TO INCREASE
PLACEMENT STABILITY FOR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE AND ENSURE TIMELY
ADJUDICATION OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS WHILE PRESERVING A
FOSTER CHILD CONFIDENTIALITY
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
INCREDIBLE SENSITIVITY OF
JUVENILE COURT RECORDS I KNOW
THAT THE BILL INCLUDES SEVERAL
SAFEGUARDS INCLUDING CLEAR
LANGUAGE OF THE RECORDS COULD
NOT BE USED TO BE ON THE SCOPE
OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
AND A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ISSUE REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE
SPECIFYING WHAT RECORDS ARE
PERMANENT FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS
THANK YOU TO SENATOR -- BURKE
FOR AUTHOR IN THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEES AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF -- SP
TEN SEVENTY ONE THE BEGIN WITH
YOUR ROOM TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
-- SAY NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO WITNESSES
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. AT TEN SEVENTY ONE
DO YOU LIKE THE COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN SEVENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TEN
SEVENTY ONE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE -- GETCHELL -- TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SAN ON
COMING BEFORE THE MICROPHONES
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SEVENTY
ONE NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
SURE IF YOU LIKE THE
COMMON IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME IT ONE MONTH
THE LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THIRTY AIRLINES OPENS
FOR
OUR SPONSORS NINE THIRTY
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN Q.
I THANK YOU MODERATOR WITH
THAT LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HEY SEEING NONE --
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CORTESE -- SIR -- BURKE A.
RIVER AGAIN WHY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
-- -- AND THIS I THINK YOU
POINTED OUT SO IMPORTANT TO
BE SURE THAT WE CAN GET HELP
FOR HIS CHILDREN -- IN A
TIMELY MANNER NOT HAVE I GUESS
LEGALISTIC AND BUREAUCRATIC
OUT THE BARRIERS TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES
FOR THEM I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT BETTER
MYSELF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I BOTH OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH SAYS THERE -- BURKE -- SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BEFORE
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY IT'S
BEEN -- SECONDED BY CENTER
CORTESE CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TEN HI
CAN I JONES JONES
I COURTESY OF THE I
HURTADO HURTADO
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I
OKAY SO I BELIEVE THAT
BILLS OUT FOUR ZERO EXT
OKAY THANK YOU NUMBER R. EIGHT
-- NEXT ITEM IS ACTUALLY
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB TEN
NINETY ONE BY CENTER TIDO
SURTEES YOU YOU GOING TO
BE PRESENTING THAT STILL
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
IT'S GOING TO ONE
ACTUALLY AND THEN
THERE'S A DRAWS A BILL
OKAY PLEASE BEGIN YEAH I
THINK IT WAS HERE IN THE
IN SENATORS OF THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR -- CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES TODAY I
PRESENT S. B. TEN NINETY ONE
THE TARGETED FAMILY FINALLY
MAKE IT EASIER FOR YOUTH IN
LONG TERM FOSTER CARE WHICH
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO FUND COMPETITIVE CONTRACTS
WITH C. B. O. S. WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE ALLOCATIONS
TO COUNTIES IN INDIAN TRIBES
WERE BOTH TO SUPPORT NEW OR
EXPANDED FAMILY FIND YOU TO
GIVE A PROGRAMS SB TEN NINETY
ONE WILL FUND PROGRAMS WILL
SUPPORT EVERY CHILD AND YOUNG
PERSON FOSTER CARE TO PURSUE
CARRYING SUPPORTED CONNECTIONS
TO RELATIVE AND NON RELATIVE
FAMILY THE BILL COMPASSES THIS
THROUGH TARGETED F. F. THE
EFFORTS THAT FOCUS ON CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
CARE FOR TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
THE ISSUE IS -- THAT RESEARCHERS
FOUND THE CHILDREN FOR SECURE
EXPERIENCE GREATER PLACEMENT
STABILITY HAVE BETTER MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH OUTCOMES
IN CHILDREN PLACED WITH NON
RELATIVES ADDITIONALLY CHILDREN
PLACED WITH RELATIVES CONTINUE
TO REACH PERMANENCY THROUGH
REUNIFICATION GUARDIANSHIP
OR ADOPTION AT MUCH HIGHER
RATES THAN THOSE PLACED WITH
NON RELATIVES HAVE LOWER
RATES OF REENTRY ASSEMBLY
FUNNY ENGAGEMENT OFFERS
FOSTER CHILDREN THE YOUTH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE
LEGAL PERMANENCY WHICH MEDICAL
GUARDIANSHIP REUNIFICATION
ADOPTION OR EMOTIONAL PERMANENCY
WHICH REFERS TO ESTABLISHING
A LIFELONG RELATIONSHIP WITH
AN ADULT WHO UNCONDITIONALLY
SUPPORT MAINTAIN HEALTHY CONTACT
WITH A CHILD BEYOND THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN EXISTING LAW RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY FINING
BY REQUIRING COUNTIES MAKING
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY
LOCATE AND NOTIFY RELATIVES WITH
WHOM THE CHILD MAY POTENTIALLY
BE PLACED WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
OF A CHILD'S REMOVAL FROM THEIR
HOME HOWEVER CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT HAVE A STATEWIDE COORDINATED
EFFORT OR DEDICATED STATEWIDE
FUNDING STREAM TO IMPLEMENT
FAMILY FUN ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS
PRICKLY EXTENDED FAMILY HAVE
LOST CONTACT WITH THE CHILD IN
OR WHAT OR WHERE THAT A RELATIVE
SHELTER USES IN FOSTER CARE WITH
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AS A RESULT
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED TWELVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE AT AGE SEVENTEEN
OR YOUNGER WHO DIDN'T CARE FOR
AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
ARE NOT LIVING WITH A RELATIVE
NO LONGER HAVE REUNIFICATION
THEIR CASE PLAN AND ARE NOT
LIVING WITH HIM IN THE PROCESS
OF ADOPTING THEM OR TAKING THEM
INTO GUARDIANSHIP THIS NUMBER
REPRESENTS TWENTY PERCENT ONE
IN FIVE OF ALL YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE SB TEN ANYONE PROPOSES
TO ADDRESS THIS BY REQUIRING
STATEWIDE COORDINATED EFFORT
IN FUNDING FOR THAT EFFORT
THROUGH A CORRESPONDING BUDGET
REQUESTS THAT WILL SUPPORT NEW
OR EXPANDED INTENSIVE FAMILY
FINING ENGAGE OF PROGRAMS THESE
EFFORTS WILL TARGET YOUTH WHO
HAVE BEEN IN FOSTER CARE FOR AT
LEAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS WELL
AFTER EFFORTS MADE TO CONNECT
CHILDREN USED THEIR FAMILY
DURING THEIR INITIAL THIRTY DAYS
OF CARE BY FOCUSING ON THESE
YOUTH WITH LITTLE IN THE WAY
OF EXISTING PERMANENCY PLANNING
SB TEN NINETY ONE REDOUBLED
EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT NO YOUTH
EXITS FOSTER CARE WITHOUT A
LONG TERM CONNECTION THE LEVINE
IN SUPPORT OF PERSONS I'D NOW
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO A PRIMARY
WITNESSES A JOINING ME TODAY BY
PHONE IS JOE FORD CHIEF PROGRAM
OFFICER OF SYCAMORES LOS ANGELES
BASED FAMILY SERVICES PROVIDER
THAT SPECIALIZES IN INTENSIVE
FAMILY FUNDING FOR YOUTH
WHO BEEN IN FOSTER CARE FOR
EXTEND PERIOD OF TIME END HOPE
KAYMER POLICY ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES WHICH IS
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CHILDREN YOU AND
AS I MENTIONED WHO'S A SPONSOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU TEARS
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVALS THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE JOE FORD
FROM SYCAMORES CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES AND HOPE CHAMBER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES I WILL
BEGIN WITH THE -- JOE FORD
WHAT'S YOUR OPINION IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY BY
JOE FORTY PROGRAM OFFICER IT'S
BECOME MORE THAN ON BEHALF OF
THE SIXTEEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
WE SERVE ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE
WHAT IS THE STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SENATE BILL IN NINETY
ONE FUNDS FROM THE STATE AND
L. A. COUNTY IN IT WAS MORE
TO PROVIDE A CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES THE INDIVIDUALIZED
OF THE FOSTER YOUTH IN THEIR
CARE GIVERS FOR THESE SERVICES
RANGING FROM SHORT FORM
THE DIGITAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
OF FOSTER CARE -- APPROPRIATION
SERVICES FOUR FIGURE MUCH
MORE FOR DECADES SYCAMORES
HAS REMAINED COMMITTED TO THE
BEST PRACTICE OF PROVIDING
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT
BECAUSE OF THE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH IN CARE UNMET
NEED FOR FOSTER YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCE CHRONIC MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES -- A LACK OF FAMILY
CONNECTION WHAT FOSTER YOU THE
RECONNECTED TO THEIR FAMILIES
SO BIG BEHAVIORS ARE EMPHASISED
THAT WE PREVIOUSLY WITH THIS
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASE WE
NEED IMMEDIATE IMPROVEMENTS
LEAD TO HEALING LESS RELIABLE
PUBLIC SERVICES IN IN DOING
MEANINGFUL CONNECTION WITH
THEIR FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL TO HELPING FOSTER
YOU PROFESSIONALLY RECONNECT
WITH FAMILY BY INCREASING
SELF SUFFICIENCY THE FUNDING
FOR THE WAS ABLE TO OFFSET THE
PROVIDING THESE CRUCIAL SERVICES
THE GENEROSITY OF OUR L. A.
COUNTY PARDON WHAT OUTCOMES
FOR FAMILY FUN NEED ENGAGEMENT
OR NO THERE'S NO DEDICATED
STATE FUNDING TO MAKE THESE
SERVICES MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE
ALL YOU FOR THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING SENATE BILL
TEN NINETY ONE LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD SUPPORT STATEWIDE
FAMILY IN BLIGHTED ENGAGEMENT
TECHNIQUES FOR FOSTER YOUTH WHO
HAVE BEEN IN OUT OF HOME CARE
FOR LONGER THAN TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS FINALLY THE POLITICAL
WITH A BRIEF EXAMPLE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO WOULD TRANSFORM
TO OUR FAMILY SEARCH AND
ENGAGEMENT YEAH I WAS REMOVED
FROM THE MONARCHY WAS THREE
YEARS OLD AND REMAINED IN FOSTER
CARE FOR YEARS THEN CAME THE
SYCAMORES WHO ARE SHELTERED HERE
AT AGE SIXTEEN LARGELY BECAUSE
NO OTHER ORGANIZATION WOULD
TAKE HIM TO SUBMIT AN BEHAVIORS
ONE PLACE THAT OUR PROGRAM WE
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDED FELLOWSHIPS
ENGAGEMENT WOULD RESULT IN IT
FIVE FINALLY HIS MOM HAD GIVEN
UP ON HIM IN FLORIDA WITH MORE
WHO WERE OUT TO OUR CALIFORNIA
WE CAUGHT EACH -- SUBSEQUENTLY
BLEW HIM BACK TO FLORIDA WHERE
HE DISCOVERED FAMILY MEMBERS
HE HAD NEVER KNEW WE HAD WELL
STORY SHORT WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN IS BIG BEHAVIORS
IN JOHN ENDED UP EXCELLING IN
SCHOOL IN THE COMMUNITY AND
WORKING THROUGH TOUGH WILL
BE A MASSIVE CRITICAL FOSTER
CARE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU NOW
LET'S BRING ON HOPE TAMAR LEFT
TO A MINUTE AND TWENTY SECONDS
H. R. THANK YOU CARE PAN
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WILL KEEP
THIS BRIEF AND MANY MAHOOD
CAME A POLICY ADVOCATE AT THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HOW THE
FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE PROUD TO
BE SPONSORING SB TEN NINETY ONE
AND OUR MEMBERS THE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES
WITH THEIR CROSS CALIFORNIA
WITNESSED EVERY SINGLE DAY
THE PROFOUND IMPACT STRONG
CONNECTION TO A K. AT ALL HOW
THAN THE LIFE AND WELL BEING OF
A FOSTER CHILD WE KNOW FAMILY
FIGHTING WORKS AND YET THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN STATEWIDE DEDICATED
FUNDING STREAM FOR FAMILY
FINDING FOR USE WITH EXTENDED
STAYS IN CARE FOR TOO MANY YEARS
AND CONNECTIONS ARE NOT MADE
IN THE INITIAL THIRTY DAYS THIS
BILL TARGET FOR MORE THAN TWELVE
THOUSAND CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN
CARE FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS
WHO DO NOT HAVE REUNIFICATION
IN THAT CASE THEN THE ISSUES
AT CORTESE AT SOME OF THE
RECORD HE SHARED I REPRESENT
TWENTY PERCENT OF ALL CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE RIGHT A VERY
HIGH RISK OF HAVING A LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP OKAY THE ALLIANCE
AND THE FUNDAMENTAL BELIEF THAT
ALL FIVE CHILDREN STEP LIFELONG
SUPPORT TO CONNECTIONS THAT HELP
TO LET THEM FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR EYES NOT
AN ATHLETE TEN NINETY ONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THANKS
SO MUCH FOR TESTIMONY WITHOUT
MOVED TO THE DIGITAL WITNESSES
AND TEST AND IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN NINETY ONE WILL BEGIN WITH
ROOM TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WELCOME CENTER PAN CRIST EMPOWER
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SEEN OTHER WITNESS COMING
-- APPROACHING A MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
NINETY ONE NAME OR EXISTENCE
THE COMPANY'S SUPPORT OF
SB TEN NINETY ONE MIN PRESS
ONE ZERO OF THEIR LIVES
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS JONATHAN GO WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING STRONG SUPPORT
THAT SB TEN NINETY ONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANKS THE NEXT
WITNESS NEXT TO THE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS DANIEL ONE GROW
WITH CHILDREN NOW CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN NINETY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT WITH LINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MALAYSIAN
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND STRONG SUPPORT
-- SB TEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU
ALL THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON PICNIC BAN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATES
ASSOCIATION -- CALIFORNIA
COP THAT IS DEPORTED SB
TEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO GO TO LINE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU KERRY AND FERAL
HINES ON BEHALF OF THE TO DEL
MAR CAL AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES CALLING TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB TEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE RAIN MANTENO REDWOOD
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ONE
ZERO NINE ONE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS NEXT TO THE TWO LINES
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI SONYA FONTENELLE FROM
LILLY PUT A PART OF WAY FINDER
FAMILY SERVICES CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THE DEADLINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SEVENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
EIGHTY GREEN CALLING FROM
LILLY PUT A PART OF WAY FINDER
FAMILY SERVICES CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT SB TEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN HERE ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
MODERATOR NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN NINETY ONE WE DO NOT HAVE
IAN SCHEDULED LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION FOR TESTIMONY
SO WILL YOU IN WITH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
TEN NINETY ONE -- BEGINS HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SAYING NO AND APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED -- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE THROUGH IT
THIS IS SWITCH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN NINETY ONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
FIND OPPOSITION TO THE SP
TEN NINETY ONE MIN PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME
THE DALLAS MORNING Q. RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATE OR
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M OF THE BILL RIGHT BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR JONES
-- SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT CIRCLE TRACY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR PRESENT
THIS BILL BEHALF OF SENATOR
TADO DIÇN FAMILY FINDING IS
SO IMPORTANT AND BE ABLE TO
EXTEND THIS BEYOND JUST INITIAL
PERIOD THESE WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL FOR FOSTER YOUTH I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THOSE SO THANK
YOU MR HERE IN AND I THINK IT
BUILDS ON -- A LONG HISTORY OF
ADVANCEMENT IN THIS AREA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE SO THE
MOTION IS -- DO PASSED
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BEEN SECONDED BY SENATOR JOHN
CONSULTING'S CALL THE ROLL
CAN I CAN I JONES
JONES I COULD NOT SEE
OR DOES HE I HURTADO
HURTADO KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER OKAY THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTES -- THE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED BY SENATOR ALSO WELCOME
THE FIGURES TO GET OVER THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS S. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED WILL HELP FOSTER YOUTH
THAT AGE OUT OF THE STATE'S
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM SECURE
THANK OF SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME OR SSI BENEFITS THIS
WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
ASSISTANCE TO YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE YOUTH WHO
AGE OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM EACH YEAR AND UP
HOMELESS OR INCARCERATED WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF EXITING CARE
YOUTH WITH DISABILITIES BEAR AN
EVEN GREATER RISK OF NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES IN ADULTHOOD THEN THE
GENERAL FOSTER CARE POPULATION
WITHOUT FINANCIAL RESOURCES
YOU'VE WHOSE DISABILITIES ARE
SEVERE ENOUGH TO PREVENT THEM
FROM ENGAGING IN FULL TIME
WORK ARE AT RISK OF POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS AS A SIDE BENEFITS
PROVIDE MONTHLY CASH ASSISTANCE
HEALTH INSURANCE AND ALSO HAS
PROGRAMS FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH TO ENGAGE A SUPPORTED
WORK OPPORTUNITIES HOWEVER
MANY TECHNICAL BERRIES EXISTS
TO ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN AS
A SILAGE ABILITY FOR YOUTH IN
CARE THERE IS ALSO A GAP
IN EXISTING LAW THAT LEAVES OUT
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS WHO ARE
FOSTER YOUTH AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE FROM RECEIVING SSI
SCREENING APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
AND ONGOING SUPPORT FROM THE
COUNTIES WHILE THEY ARE STILL
IN CARE SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED WILL
STRENGTHEN SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH WITH DISABILITIES BY
EXTENDING AS THE SITE SCREENING
AND APPLICATION DUTIES TO NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS AND ENSURING
THEY CONTINUE RECEIVING SUPPORT
AND MAINTAINING SSI ELIGIBILITY
AS ADULTS THIS WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
OFTEN DON'T HAVE THE FAMILY OR
SUPPORT NETWORKS TO ASSIST THEM
TODAY OUR MESSAGE HERE I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES HERE TO SUPPORT
-- SABRINA FORTE DIRECTOR POLICY
AND IMPACT LITIGATION WITH
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
ARE SPONSORING ORGANIZATION
AND STEVE WEISS THE MANAGING
ATTORNEY FOR SOCIAL SECURITY
DISABILITY AND SSI WITH BAY AREA
LEGALLY EXCELLENT -- SO I
UNDERSTAND BOTH WITH MR HERE IN
PERSON AND WELCOME -- SO WE'LL
BEGIN WITH A SUBPOENA FOR THANK
YOU SENATOR ALSO AND I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS AND THE YOUTH LAW CENTER
HAVE PARTNERED TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL AND WE ARE ALSO
PARTNER CO SPONSORS ON AB TWELVE
OVER A DECADE AGO ESTABLISHING
CALIFORNIA'S EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM AND IN DOING THAT
IT WAS ALWAYS OUR INTENTION THAT
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SAME SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT MINOR DEPENDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO PLACEMENTS
HEALTHCARE CASE WORKER SUPPORT
ETCETERA SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED
FURTHERS THAT VISION OF EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE BUT TAKING EXISTING
SUPPORTS DESIGNED TO LINK MINOR
FOSTER YOUTH WITH US ASIDE
AND EXTENDING THOSE SUPPORTS
ANOTHER DEPENDENCE FOR ALL THE
REASONS DESCRIBED BY SENATOR
ALSO AS A SIDE BENEFITS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOUNG ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND CERTAIN
COUNTIES AS MY COLLEAGUE WILL
SPEAK NEXT -- WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THE BEGUN TO SCREEN AND APPLY
FOR SSI ON BEHALF OF NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS THAT'S NOT TRUE FOR
THE MAJORITY EVEN IN COUNTIES
THAT PROVIDE THIS ASSISTANCE WE
HEAR THAT MANY TRANSITION NEED
TO CLIENTS WHO AGE OUT OF CARE
-- SAY THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE AN APPLICATION
PENDING UNTIL THEY'VE AGED
OUT OF CARE OR UNTIL THAT
APPLICATION HAS BEEN DENIED
ONE OF THE ALLIANCE'S CLIENTS
WHO ALL CALL DALE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSES HE WAS NOT SCREENED
FOR SSI AS A TEENAGER WHILE
HE WAS IN FOSTER CARE WHEN
HE CAME IN ON MINOR DEPENDENT
HIS CARE GIVER ADVOCATED FOR
YEARS FOR A SOCIAL WORKER
TO SUBMIT AN SSI APPLICATION
THE APPLICATION WAS SUBMITTED
RIGHT BEFORE DEAL TURNED TWENTY
ONE THE APPLICATION HAS BEEN
PENDING HE'S TWENTY TWO NOW AND
IT IS DISABILITIES CONTINUE TO
POSE BARRIERS TO DISABILITY AND
SELF SUFFICIENCY HE LIKELY LIVES
WITH THE LOVING GRANDMOTHER BUT
SHE'S GROWN OLDER AND WORRIES
EVERY DAY WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
HIM WHEN SHE'S NO LONGER ABLE
TO PROVIDE FOR HIS CARE UNDER S.
B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED DEAL SOCIAL
WORKER WOULD HAVE HAD TO SUBMIT
AN APPLICATION ON DEALS BE HAPPY
EVEN THOUGH HE HAD BECOME A NINE
MINOR DEPENDENTS SB THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ALSO INCORPORATES BEST
PRACTICES AND MAXIMIZE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT YOUTH WHO MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR SSI WILL BE LINKED
TO IT BEFORE THEY AGE OUT OF
CARE THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I THOUGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW LET'S BRING UP FOR US THE
VOICE WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
OF CARE PLAN IN MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU CENTER VERIZON
OF STEVE Y. SUMMER REGIONAL
MANAGING ATTORNEY OF BAY AREA
LEGAL AID AND HERE IN SUPPORT
-- I OVERSEE OURSELVES SECURITY
NECESSARY PRACTICE I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND WE'VE SPECIFICALLY
WORK WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY TO
REPRESENT -- SYSTEM INVOLVED
YOUTH FOR OVER TEN YEARS
NOW -- I JOIN THE COMMENTS
OF SPRING FORTE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL
TO EXTEND THE SERVICES AND
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE AVAILABLE
TO NON MINOR DEPENDENTS --
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
LOOKING BEYOND THE EXISTING
MANDATES OF SCREENING APPLYING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S ACTUAL
REPRESENTATION AND ADVOCACY OF
MANY OF THESE CASES ARE DENIED
INITIALLY IN NEED TO APPEAL
AND THE CURRENT MANDATE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
ENSURE THAT YOUTH REPRESENTED
IN THOSE APPEALS -- BUT MOST
PEOPLE WHO APPLY FOR THESE
BENEFITS ARE DENIED AND MOST
PEOPLE REPEAL AND GO TO HEARING
OUR SUCCESSFUL AND THEN MORE
SO IF THEY'RE REPRESENTED --
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT
FURTHER WAYS TO STRENGTHEN THESE
PROGRAMS -- AND THEN --
PHILOSOPHICALLY WITH WITH REGARD
TO NAM INTERDEPENDENCE YOUTH
WERE FOUND ELIGIBLE AS A MINOR
ARE REVIEWED BY SOCIAL SECURITY
AT AGE EIGHTEEN TO SEE IF THEY
MEET THE ADULTS STANDARD --
IN FORTY PERCENT ARE REMOVED
AT THAT POINT WHICH CAN HAPPEN
AT EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN OR
TWENTY -- BUT AGAIN THERE'S NO
ASSURANCE THAT THOSE YOUTH ARE
REPRESENTED WITH APPEALS BUT
IF THEY ARE REPRESENTED THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO STAY I NEED IN
A CENTER DORADO MENTION THERE'S
-- DRAWS A MENTION THERE'S OF
NOW TWENTY YOUR STUDIES GOING
BACK TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX THAT
FOLLOWED YOUTH FOR TWENTY YEARS
AND FOUND OF THAT OVER THAT
TIME THOSE WHO WERE CUT OFF AS
SOCIETY J. TEAM HAD A MUCH
HIGHER -- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT OVERWHELMINGLY FOR
OF WHAT ARE DESCRIBED AS INCOME
GENERATING CRIME SO --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SPONSORING
THIS I THINK IT'S A GREAT STEP
BUT I THINK THERE'S MORE THAT
WE COULD DO THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU LET'S ALL MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED WILL
BEGIN AND HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED A NON APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
RELATED BY SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO OPPOSITE TO MINE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON COULD MAKE AN
IMPACT CALIFORNIA KAPIT REPORT
OF AT THIRTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TO LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN HUNDRED THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER THREE THE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARK AND UNITED
TERRIBLE POLITY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
JUST A MOMENT
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS TORRENT
OF THE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS GIVE ACTION CALLING
IT SUPPORT AS HE THIRTEEN
POINT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THE STANDARD OTHERS IN Q. THANKS
VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY SCHEDULE LEAD WITNESSES FOR
TESTIMONY SO LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED ST ON APPROACHING
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES TO WITNESSES
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED
YOU LIKE PASSED THE FINAL
POSITION OF IT THE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AND THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
HERE I THANK YOU -- MODERATOR
LET'S BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ATTENDED BY SARAH CARMICHAEL
OKAY SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS -- CENTER ALSO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT -- -- -- FOSTER
YOUTH ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
HAVE DISABILITIES ALREADY
DISADVANTAGED BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SYSTEMS
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO STAY
ON SSI IF THEY'RE A QUALIFY
FOR US IS THERE A ON SSI
INTO US DAHLE HOOD I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE AS WE ARE BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR RAZA SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY IT'S
BEEN SECONDED BY CENTCOM LONGER
CONSULTANCIES CALL THE ROLL TEN
HI CAN I JONES I'VE
JONES I COURTESY
COURTESY I HER DAUGHTER
HER DAUGHTER KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I OKAY THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES IT'S FOUR ZERO
THE BILL BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER AND
MEMBERS OF THE DRAWS OF RIGHT
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB EIGHT SEVENTY
BY CENTER PORTANTINO WELCOME
ZERO
THANK YOU A CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO --
A KNOWLEDGE THAT -- SENATOR
WILK IS A JOINT AUTHOR THIS BILL
SO AND MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE
OF THAT TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP EIGHT SEVENTY WHICH WOULD
INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S AGE
OF ON SITE ANSETT DEFINITION
OF DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
DISABILITY FROM EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD THIS CHANGE
WOULD EXPAND ELIGIBILITY TO
SERVICES OFFERED BY REGIONAL
CENTERS WITH IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
WIDELY ACCEPTED KNOWLEDGE THAT
BY HEALTH AND SCIENCE COMMUNITY
THAT THE RAIN DOES NOT STOP
DEVELOPING AFTER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN RATHER CONTINUES TO
DEVELOP UNTIL AT LEAST TWENTY
TWO IN FACT THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
FACT FORTY FOUR YEARS AGO BY
INCREASING THE AGE OF ONSET
DEFINITION OF DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABILITY TO TWENTY TWO IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND
THIRTY EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
STATES FOLLOWED BY RAISING
THEIR AGE OF ONSET THRESHOLD TO
TWENTY TWO AS WELL CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES FRANKLY TO BE AN OUT
LIAR WITH TWELVE OTHER STATES
BEHIND THE TIMES AND FRANKLY
DOING A DISSERVICE TO THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE LEAVING MANY
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THEY NEED AND FRANKLY
DESERVE ON THE PHONE TODAY I
HAVE A JIM O'HARA FATHER BROUGHT
THIS ISSUE TO MY ATTENTION AND
DR J. D. THE FORMER CHIEF
OF BRAIN IMAGING AT THE CHILD
PSYCH PSYCHIATRIC BRANCH OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF MENTAL
HEALTH FROM NINETEEN NINETY NINE
TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
WHEN APPROPRIATE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATE FORTINO MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING UP THE LINES JIM --
HERR AND -- DR J.
E. EIGHT AT J. E. AID FROM
UC SAN DIEGO I APOLOGIZE IF
I MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME SO
BEGIN WITH -- -- JIM O'HARE
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME I YES
I CAN'T PLEASE SERBIAN
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER PANIC
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WISH TO
THANK US SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
THE LONGSTANDING INEQUITY IN
OUR DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MY SON JIM BUT ALSO
FOR THE OTHER YOUNG DISABLED
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED BY THIS
INEQUITY CANNOT ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES AS A BOY MY SON WAS
AN HONOR STUDENT FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD HE WAS A BRILLIANT COMPUTER
PROGRAMMER WHO SOLD SOFTWARE IN
A RETAIL STORE FOR MINIMUM WAGE
FOR MOONLIGHTING ON THE SIDE
FOR THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESS SPEND SET
UP THEIR COMPUTER SYSTEMS AT AGE
SIXTEEN HE BOUGHT HIS FIRST CAR
WITH HIS OWN MONEY AND CHERISHED
HIS EMERGING INDEPENDENCE AT
AGE EIGHTEEN AFTER GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL WITH PLANS TO
PURSUE A CAREER IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE MY SON'S FUTURE CAME
TO AN ABRUPT HALT THIS CAR WAS
BROADSIDED BY AN EIGHTEEN WHEEL
TRUCK AND ENTERPRISING YOUNG
MAN WAS SUDDENLY REDUCED TO A
VEGETATIVE STATE AS A PARENT
THE PAIN OF SEEING HIM THIS WAY
WAS BEYOND ANYTHING I THOUGHT
POSSIBLE TO INDOOR AFTER TWO
MONTHS IN A DEEP COMA HIS EYES
BEGAN TO OPEN BUT THEY WERE
UNRESPONSIVE THE DOCTORS TRIED
BIGGER THERAPY BECAUSE NO WHERE
FOR TWO MORE MONTHS I WAS TOLD
TO LOOK FOR A NURSING HOME I
VISITED SEVERAL NURSING HOMES
ONE STILL HAUNTS ME THE ENTIRE
TIME I WAS VERY YOUNG MAN AND
ONE OF THE ROOMS WERE SHOUTING
LOUDLY AND CRUNCHING GROUSES
EFFECTIVELY TRYING TO GET
SOMEONE'S ATTENTION I LOOK IN
HIS ROOM AND I SAW I'M STRAPPED
TO THE BED WHEN HE SAW ME HE
BECAME VERY CALL HE GRUNTED
QUIETLY TO ME AS IT IS CRUNCH
FOR WORDS I LISTENED AND NODDED
AS IF I UNDERSTOOD AND HE SEEMED
SO GRATEFUL JUST TO HAVE SOMEONE
THERE WITH HIM WHEN I LEFT I
HEARD HIM SHOUTING DESPERATELY
AGAIN I RETURN TO THE HOSPITAL
THAT FINAL NIGHT HAUNTED BY
THE IMAGES OF NURSING HOMES AND
DECIDED TO FIGHT FOR MY SON BUT
MY SON IT TURNS EIGHTEEN SHORTLY
BEFORE THE ACCIDENT HE WAS NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES WHEN THE INSURANCE
COMPANY PULLED THE PLUG I WAS
AGAIN TOLD TO FIND A LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY I WASN'T READY
TO DO THAT INSTEAD I BROUGHT
HIM HOME AND CONSTRUCTED A HOME
SCHOOLING PROGRAMS FORM AND
SUPPLEMENTED IT WITHOUT VISION
TENANTS PUBLIC HEARING
OF TWO YEARS HE REBUILT HIS
MEMORIES READING AND MATH SKILLS
AND STANDARDS DOCTORS WITH HIS
SELF SUFFICIENCY THE PHRASE
WAS THE SHOWS WHAT WE CAN DO
WHEN YOU HAVE EARLY INTERVENTION
AND DON'T GIVE UP I URGE YOU
TO VOTE FOR SB EIGHT SEVEN
THESE HELP THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
STRUGGLE TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH
-- MISTER HER FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY LET'S NOW BRING ON --
DR J. HE'D GET POSITIVE
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME -- YOU
HAVE A MINUTE AND FORTY SECONDS
OKAY YEP BUT LOCATION WAS THAT
LET'S FIGHT ON AND THEY GAVE
THEM FOR THE LAST THREE DECADES
OF MY LIFE I RECOMMEND TO MAP
HOW THE BRAIN DEVELOPS AND TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT INFLUENCE
THAT FOR BETTER OR WORSE THAN
THE TECHNICIANS AND HEALTH --
PROOF THAT AT THE THE NHL NOW
AT UC SAN DIEGO WHERE WE'RE
PROBABLY TWELVE THOUSAND USE
AND THE BRAIN DEVELOPMENT --
WILL BEGAN AT THE STUDY WE
ARE DEBATING WHETHER WE SHOULD
FOLLOW UP PARTICIPANTS UNTIL AGE
SIXTEEN OR EIGHTEEN BY SIXTEEN
PEOPLE CAN WIN GOLD MEDALS AT
THE OLYMPICS AND IN THE PAST
BEING TO HAVE BEEN A FUNCTIONING
PRETTY MUCH OF THE GULF THAT
MAYBE IT ONLY IF SOCIETY
CHANGES NOT VALIDATE THAT WOULD
STRETCHING THAT OUT AND SO
WE DECIDED PLAYED SAFE AND --
SHOOT -- TAKE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SMALLER
SHOCKED WHEN THEY THEY CAME
IN AND NOT ONLY ARE THERE WITH
REFLECT CHANGES TACTICS IN AN
INSTANT BUT WELL ON INTO THEIR
TWENTIES RIDDICK OF THE LATELY
THE FACT THAT WE CHECKED IN
AND THEN -- THE TECH BEGAN AND
IT SAID HELD FIRM BUT IN SOME
INDEPENDENT SITE WOULDN'T
DOESN'T THE RESEARCH TEAM
SPROUT THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
REASONABLE PEOPLE COULD HAVE
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER THE
MATURATION LEVELS OUT AT
TWENTY THREE OR TWENTY FIVE
OR TWENTY SEVEN BUT I DON'T
KNOW OF A SINGLE DEVELOPMENTAL
NEUROSCIENTISTS TO ARGUE FOR
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN -- IT'S
NOT BROKEN OR DEFECTIVE BEFORE
THAT BUT IT'S NOT AS GOOD AS
IT'S GOING TO GET -- AND GO
FROM A SCIENTIFIC STANDPOINT
THIS IS A -- YOU'RE NOT A SLAM
DUNK IN TERMS OF THE ON GOING
ACTIVATION INTO THE TWENTIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY BACK TO EAT
DID YOU FINISH START
I'M DONE YES OKAY I THANK THANK
YOU SIR I APOLOGIZE I WASN'T
SURE ABOUT SO I THINK SO MUCH --
FOR BOTH OF OUR WITNESSES THAT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HE WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF -- SB EIGHT SEVENTY
-- HERE LET'S BEGIN AND HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ST ON
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONES --
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY
NAME FOR EXIST IN A POSITION
RELATED TO FIND SUPPORT
OF SB SEVENTY HERE PRESS
ONE ZERO FIVE EITHER LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS JOHN CAN GO
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE S. B. EIGHT SEVEN B. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
NICE TO GO TO LINE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THREE TO
ANDERSON ON THE TOP OF THE ARC
AND UNITED TERRIBLE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THERE'S NO NOTHING HERE RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH WELL NOW MOVES
TO IT THIS IS AN OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT SEVENTY AND
WE DO HAVE A LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION DANIEL SABINO
-- FROM THE ASSOCIATION
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WHO
I BELIEVE WILL BE ON THE LINE
SO MODERATELY PLEASE BRING --
DANIELSON SABINA ON TO LINE
AND -- YES REALLY ALL RIGHT
AND THAT SINCE THE -- PROPONENTS
AT FOUR MINUTES YOU CAN HAVE
FOUR MINUTES BUT YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO USE ALL FOUR
MINUTES IF YOU DON'T WISH TO
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU VETR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DANIEL SABINO
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT
IN OPPOSITION WE ARE IN THE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
BUT WE HAVE NO OBJECTION TO
THE CONCEPT OF CHANGING THE
AGE OF ELIGIBILITY TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN THERE ARE TWO VERY
IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN FROM POLICY STANDPOINT
THE PARTICULARLY A SERVICE
POPULATION FIRST WE WOULD NEED
TO SEE THE REMOVAL OF THE WEEK
MEDIAN RATE STRUCTURE WHICH IS A
STRUCTURE THAT PREVENTS REGIONAL
CENTERS FROM FUNDING SERVICES
THAT THE COSTS NEEDED TO STAY
IN THE WITHOUT THE SERVICES
THERE WILL SIMPLY BE NOTHING
AVAILABLE FOR NEW CLIENTS
SECONDLY THERE'S A CHANGE THAT
WILL ALLOW REGIONAL CENTERS TO
SUPPORT THE CREATION IS SERVICES
WHICH WOULD BE ALLOWED IN ONCE
AGAIN THE USE OF PURPOSES OF
SURPLUS FUNDS FOR STARTING
UP NEW PROGRAMS HISTORICALLY
REGIONAL CENTERS WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS FINANCIAL SUPPORT
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT WERE SEEKING TO ENTER
THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES ARENA TO MEET EXISTING
NEEDS OR IN THIS CASE NEW NEEDS
WITHOUT THE START UP FUNDING
IF IT COMES VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO ENTER THIS
MARKET AND PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT ARE FOLKS DESERVE AND
NEED HELP WITH THE REMOVAL OF
BOTH THE MEDIAN RATE AND THE
STARTUP FUNDING PROHIBITION
REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK CHU DRESS THESE NEEDS
AND THAT WOULD BE OF COURSE
A LOT OF THAT'S ACCORDING
TO THE POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL MOVE ON TO
OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
-- OF BEGIN WITH FOR YOUR IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SEEN
ON APPROACHING A MIKE FROM ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT SEVENTY
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY A
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME
WE HAVE NO IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS WE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
COME UNDER SENATE FORTINO
-- AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
CERTAINLY AS A PEDIATRICIAN AYE
-- AYE TO SECOND -- HERE
YOUR EXPERT TESTIMONY ABOUT
-- FROM FROM YOUR EXPERT --
ABOUT THE FACT THAT DEVELOPMENT
DOESN'T STOP AT EIGHTEEN AT
CONTINUES AND -- THAT MAKE IT
AND FROM BIOLOGICALS IT MAKES
SENSE -- BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTERS ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
PROVIDE SERVICES SO -- SO
PERHAPS IF YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT YOU CLOSE BUT CERTAINLY
-- APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND CENTER WILKES AND AND AND
AND MOVING THIS FORWARD -- SO
WITH THAT -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH OBVIOUSLY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE RESOURCES AND
THE ABILITY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION ARE
DRESSED WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
THAT IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IT'S OUT OF THE SCHOOL
THANKS SO MUCH CENTER PORTANTINO
-- SO WITH THAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
AND SPENT SEVEN WAY CENTER
COME UNDER -- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CAN
I CAN I JONES I JONES
I COURTESY COURTESY I
OUR DATA HER DATA
KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER II PHASE
THAT FILLS OUT FOUR ZERO OKAY
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
AGAIN WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON
CONSENT -- THAT'S AGAIN THAT'S
I'M NUMBER ONE SB FORTY TWO BY
CENTER DODD AYE NUMBER THREE SB
EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY CEREMONY I
AM NUMBER FOUR SB EIGHT EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT ARE LAYERED I'M
NUMBER FIVE SB NINE OH SEVEN
BY MYSELF AND PAN I NUMBER
SEVEN SB TEN FIFTY FOUR BY
CENTER UNTIL BOTH AND NUMBER
NINE SB NINE TEN NINETY BY
CENTER TADO I AM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB TEN NINETY THREE BY CENTER
HER TADO IS THERE A MOTION
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY --
SECRETASE C. R. CONTROLLED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON IT
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TEN HI CAN I JONES
JONES I COURTESY OF THE I
PATADA HURTADO
KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER II OKAY
THE CONSENT CALENDARS OUT FOUR
ZERO NOW WILL LIFT THE CALLS ON
THE -- -- THE BILL'S THAT WE'VE
HEARD THAT -- STILL HAVE NOT
BEEN OUT SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR BY CENTER SKINNER ITS OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS JONES
NO JONES NOW OKAY SO
THAT BILLS OUT OF THREE ONE
BUT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB NINE FOURTEEN BY
CENTER RUBIO A CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I JONES I
THE BILL IS OUT FOUR ZERO
FIVE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB TEN NINETY ONE BY CENTER
HER TADO I CAN SIMPLY CALL
THE ROLL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI
THAT BILLS OUT FOUR ZERO
OKAY WE'RE ALL DONE OKAY
THIS CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PRESENTERS AND I DON'T THINK ALL
THE WITNESSES WHO HAVE TESTIFIED
TODAY I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF AND A RESURGENCE -- FOR
AND AND ALSO OUR MODERATORS FOR
MAKING THIS A SMOOTH RUNNING
HEARING AND -- SO AGAIN THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE AND WITH THAT
-- THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED